Rose Royce is part of the BMW Group
organisation the BMW Group is a major
major investor in the United States when
it comes to manufacturing facilities
also generating lots of jobs in the
United States and doing lots of other
businesses between the BMW Group and the
United States so for that reason you can
say that the BMW Group brings quarrel of
wealth into the United States and we in
our group white let's say capacity are
anyhow in the belief that free trade is
fundamentally important for the world
what about the wider world at the moment
all of your cars are built here in the
United Kingdom but what about the parts
could could brexit potentially disrupt
that if you don't get free movement of
manufactured goods I don't think so
I mean Rose Royce's you could even say
part of the British brand crown jewels
and being British and to build the cars
in Britain is a fundamental part why
customers love our products all over the
world so let me say that even as being a
German I can tell you that we are
fundamentally engaged in Britain and
want to stay to be fully engaged in
Britain with our plant town and West
Sussex and for that reason I'm highly
highly interested in free trade
relations all over the world and that we
see free flow of goods but of course
also free flow of people between
countries very important for us but
presumably
you won't particularly worried
necessarily about the cost of some
imported components going up if we don't
get a free trade deal I mean I'm worried
about what I call free uncomplicated
movement of goods and that of course
includes parts our supplier network is
worldwide as you can imagine and it is
quite tricky to get parts right in time
up to our line and for that reason I
don't want to see this being slowed up
as well as I don't want to see that
qualified craftspeople are allowed to
work in the UK
or good also go abroad without any
problems for their working contract
you're standing in front of the new
phantom 8 how important launch is this
for you
I mean phantom is the flagship for ROS
ROS motorcars and the longest standing
nameplate in history of automotive
business over 90 years and it is the car
of kings queens Royals captains of
industries so for that reason a very
important launch was which had happened
end of last year and I must say this car
is the pinnacle and I'm quoting here
your colleagues they said the best car
in the world so for that reason very
important for us and how many do you
hope to sell this year result a trade
secret I mean that it's kind of a secret
because we at Rose Royce we are quite
shy when it comes to numbers but I I can
tell you that our aura book looks very
strong and I'm pleased to see that
particular customers like the new
edition of phantom massively all over
the world so if you were order today you
would probably be lucky to get delivery
and take delivery for Christmas
presumably if I have to ask you the
price I can't afford it
that's always the case when you need to
ask for a price of a rolls-royce you
should never ask